j'accueille tarak ben ammar hervé van
thin
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous on est
très flattée évidemment de vous recevoir
et vous êtes les normes producteurs vous
aussi tarak traque vous êtes l'héritier
de la dynastie ben ammar qui a longtemps
été associé c'est sarah que j'avais star
ac' bénin qui a longtemps été associé
aux destinées l'état tunisien vous est
le neveu de l'épousé de bourguiba
vous avez commencé après études à rome
comme comme assistant de production
le matin vous vous leviez pour aller
voir si les le plein des voiturettes
effet quoi vous êtes vraiment commencer
en bas ensuite vous avez emmené d'orge
luca sang en tunisie
georges locas pour la guerre des étoiles
il n'avait pas d'argent et je disais oui
à tous les metteurs en scène
quelle que soit leur nationalité une
tunisie encore pauvre et qui était
rentré dans le monde de tourisme et je
rencontre georges occase en aéroport et
il me dit est ce que tu as un décor pour
une planète toute manière je disais oui
par principe qui en ont une
une fois qu'ils étaient là je me démerde
ai trouvé un accord et la planète de la
guerre des étoiles le premier je vous
parle dire exactement 30 ans je les
remets dans un village qui s'appelle
tataouine
ouais et la planète à tourine pour les
milliards de fans
c'est un petit village dans le sud
tunisien qui a beaucoup plu à giorgio
gaza est depuis georges ou castres vient
tourner mais même plan parce que ça lui
porte bonheur il vient tourner tous les
plans de la guerre des étoiles de la
planète tataouine
même s'il fait le film ailleurs comme ça
a été le cas l'an dia
belle histoire ensuite tarak j'ai
beaucoup donné avec avec jésus vous avez
produit jésus de nazareth de zeffirelli
la vie de brian des monty python 13h45
avant jésus-christ de jean yanne et vous
avez distribué le film de mel gibson la
passion du christ j'ai vu aussi des
échecs vous savez du pirate de polanski
qui est une catastrophe pour vous vous
avez perdu combien tarak là dessus au 20
20 25 millions de dollars à presque
autant que moi un peu moi je voulais
rentrer dans les toilettes
mais je les ai récupérées ouais grâce à
un procès historique 1
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
du cinéma qu'un producteur étranger de
surcroît du tiers-monde
j'ai fait un procès à la grande major
company universal
ah oui qui a duré dix ans et j'ai gagné
parce qu'il m'avait signé un contrat
qu'ils n'ont pas respectées c'est pour
ça que j'ai perdu et l'argent et preuve
de la grande démocratie américaine
j'ai gagné devant un jury populaire
19 millions de dollars bravo encore très
réussie avec la télévision où vous êtes
associé de berlusconi avec murdoch avec
patrick le lay et tf1 le cinéma avait
associé avec dino de laurentiis
maintenant avec les frères weinstein
dans leur nouvelle société qui l'ont
créée après leur départ de miramax
alors vous avez vous êtes l'un des deux
frères weinstein légendes d'hollywood
producteur et distributeur alors
allons-y de pulp fiction reservoir dogs
kill bill sexe mensonges et vidéo cinéma
paradiso la leçon de piano
adieu ma concubine la cité de dieu
shakespeare in love game the new york 10
aviez tort le patient anglais sourire
scary movie les invasions barbares et
sin city